[Music]
so
dear prime minister you're just in a
very warm welcome to the ballymore to
the european commission um it's a
pleasure to have you here
and
i must really say that since the
beginning of uh putin's atrocious and
cruel war
we see that the transatlantic community
has been standing very strong very
united and very determined
and i think this is a great asset
in our efforts to support our ukrainian
friends as much as we can
but it also revealed a spectacular
failure of putin's plan to divide us
this unity is so strong thanks to our
unbreakable bonds
grounded in our history
our shared values and of course our
steadfast commitment to a rules-based
global order
so the european union and canada will
continue to deepen their cooperation
and work in support of the brave people
of ukraine
i want to emphasize three points
the first is that we are stepping up our
humanitarian support inside and outside
ukraine
in particular i'm very glad that i heard
that you're looking into and i'm
inviting you
to channel in kind support if possible
to ukraine via the eu civil protection
mechanism hubs they are in poland in
romania and in slovakia
and of course we will also continue to
support those who have been forced to
flee ukraine
through our complementary resettlement
resettlement efforts if they wish so
and our assistance to neighboring
countries
my second point is sanctions
we now had four waves of
unprecedented sanctions
that we have taken together
and these sanctions have taken a heavy
toll on russia's economy and its ability
to wage war
now together with our g7 partners we
will make sure to keep the pressure high
on the kremlin
restrict enforcement
and by tackling evasion and
circumvention and for that we are
establishing a dedicated g7 working
group to share information among us
to coordinate responses and to make sure
that there is no sanctions evasion
we also know that the brutal military
violence of putin's war is flanked by
attacks
of a hybrid nature in particular in
cyberspace
so therefore to counter this the
european union and canada will step up
cooperation on cyber security
and we will support the governments of
ukraine and moldova on cyber defense and
internet access
my third topic is energy
russia is not only threatening our
security architecture in the military
sense
but it is clear that our dependency of
the european union on russian fossil
fuels
also puts europe's energy security in
danger we have to get rid of our
dependency of russian fossil fuels
and as a response the european union and
canada
will take our strategic energy
cooperation
to the next level
commissioner simpson and minister
wilkinson
will meet already this week
to further discuss potential and
canadian energy supply to europe and
then the work will be followed up in a
dedicated working group
this cooperation with canada will be
part of our re-power eu plan
as you know
first aim is to massively invest in
renewables because this is a strategic
investment in our energy independence
and security
but secondly to diversify away from
russian gas towards other suppliers that
are trustworthy worthy and reliable
like for example canada and the good
part is that canada shares on top the
dedication to fight climate change and
to decarbonize our economy so we both
know
that the transition to clean energy is
the key
to phase out our dependency on fossil
fuels more generally
we are both committed to speeding up the
transition to net zero and in this
context
we will also pursue our partnership on
raw materials which is instrumental to
achieving the transition to climate
neutral economies
let me finish with one of the most
urgent issues and this is food security
we all know how important ukraine and
russia are
for the global food trade
many countries in the european
neighborhood and across the globe depend
to a large extent
on their exports from ukraine in
particular of wheat the world food
program i think 50 of the wheat of the
world's food programs is coming from
ukraine
therefore the russian aggression
to block ukrainian exports through the
black sea
is seriously endangering global food
security and this is completely immoral
the european union and canada will work
together to ensure the provision of
direct food aid
and to ramp up the supply of
agricultural products more generally
so the adjusting we have a lot in common
we're friends and partners
we share the same values and the same
goals and through this work the bond
between us will be even
[Music]
uh from the beginning of the this
challenge and quite frankly through the
beginning of our times working together
ursula has been an extraordinary partner
an extraordinary leader and particularly
when it came to
bringing the european union to a place
where sanctions could be applied
swiftly and with extraordinary strength
it was really your leadership that made
this happen and i got to see
see it up close as we were discussing in
many many small groups
how we would have to remove if russia
did the unthinkable and now that it has
the strength of your leadership and the
commitment uh across the atlantic to
holding vladimir putin to account and
making sure that he fails
in this illegal horrific
war
on innocents and on a
democratic nation is extraordinarily
important
this invasion of course is unacceptable
when i spoke with president zielinski
yesterday we discussed increasing
civilian casualties
and repeated
his call on my call
to halt russian attacks withdraw forces
and
stop committing war crimes
we vowed that canada will
continue to back ukraine wholeheartedly
but as
ursula and the european union has
demonstrated
it is not something that any one of us
has to do alone
we are doing it together and united in a
way that is demonstrating not just that
we stand for our friends and for a
fellow democracy like ukraine but we
also stand up for the values and the
pillars that underpin all of our own
democracies this is an opportunity and a
responsibility for all of us to continue
to stand up for those fundamental rights
and freedoms and stability and
international rules that have
underpinned the success of so many
people not just in europe and across the
atlantic but around the world
over the past many decades
putin's war has created a refugee crisis
today with uh president fonda lyon we'll
be talking about humanitarian support
and of course what more we'll be doing
to help
canada
of course uh will be there to welcome
people fleeing war
and
tragedy as we always are but at the same
time we're going to be stepping up to
provide help and work together to
respond to the global food security
crisis that is a real
meaningful consequence direct
consequence
of vladimir putin's illegal war
we also will continue to urge russia to
allow
for humanitarian corridors and safe
passage for civilians and for those uh
determined to help civilians
sanctions
of course even as we're dealing with the
terrible situation
in ukraine and the need to continue to
stand up to defend our democracies our
rules-based order
we have lots of other things to talk
about as well and ursula mentioned the
importance of the green transition and
energy cooperation
canada is determined
to continue to lead the way on moving
towards net zero and decarbonizing as
much as possible at the same time as we
recognize a need for people to replace
russian oil and gas
in the short term we will of course look
at ways that canada can help but the
real solution is to ensure that not only
would you be do we become less reliant
on russian oil and gas we could become
increasingly less reliant on oil and gas
altogether as a world and canada
will be there as a partner on that
we're also obviously going to continue
our work on
strengthening democracy and countering
misinformation
[Music]
state actors need to be held accountable
for their actions in cyberspace and
canada and eu will continue to make good
progress on this
there's so many things we have to talk
about i'm looking forward to sitting
down once again uh with president fonda
lyon uh we uh we have lots to do and i'm
really looking forward to our
conversation as always